Hallo Leute, mir tut immer noch das Bein weh, fast eine Woche, also eigentlich ist es nicht das Bein, es ist halt so unten am Bein, Schienbein, aber es ist besser, obwohl ich gestern Rennen war, also wer weiß, was das ist.
Moin Lukas, hast du Best-Practice-Tipps zum Schreiben von Docker-Files? Fällt mir so spontan nichts ein, in den Git-Repo einchecken, aber das hat ja mit dem Docker-File selbst nichts zu tun.
Ja, Oil ist relativ spät, ich hab echt keine Ahnung, was mir da, da fragst du mich was, fällt mir so spontan nichts ein.
Ach ja, doch, Multistage-Builds.
Multistage-Builds, also verwende Multistage-Builds, wenn möglich, das sage ich immer möglich.
Also Multistage-Build heißt, du lässt nicht alles, was du während der Build-Time brauchst, auch in deinem finalen Image drin.
Multistage-Builds.
Was ist heute geplant? Ich hatte nichts besseres zu tun, bin angekommen, nix.
Weißt du, was ich meine?
Multistage-Builds.
Also Multistage-Builds sind POG.
Du kannst im Endeffekt drei, vier Build-Steps haben mit deinem Image und am Ende kommt dann irgendein Binary raus und dann machst du ein finales Image, wo nur das Binary reinkommt und dann hast du, ja, ein Mini-Image.
Ach ja, und, und, seriously, das mag nicht Best-Practice sein, das mag vielleicht mal ein persönlicher Geschmack sein.
Nimm nicht Alpine, nimm irgendein Minimal-Debit.
Ist jetzt auch nicht so viel größer, schon größer ist nicht so viel größer, hat aber einige Probleme von Alpine nicht.
Zum Beispiel hast du keine Probleme mit teilweise DNS-Auflösungen und solchen Geschichten.
Wie gesagt, das ist kein Best-Practice.
Viele Leute schwören auf Alpine, ich nicht.
Das macht gar keinen so großen Unterschied.
Wenn du Multistage-Builds verwendest und dann irgendein Minimal-Debian oder so nimmst, irgendein Slim-Debian, Bookworm, Slim.
Was immer, dann ist das, ich weiß nicht, was der Unterschied ist, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es die paar MB ausmachen.
Übermorgen-Zwischenprüfung, ist doch nice.
Weißt du, du hast fast geschafft, also die Halbzeit, ne?
Du hast quasi mehr Zeit geschafft, als mehr Zeit noch übrig.
So musst du es sehen.
Aber mach dir noch keine Gedanken um die Zwischenprüfung, Zwischenprüfung ist easy.
Solange du, ich mach mal kurz Package ab.
Solange du ordentlich, ich weiß, dass die mittlerweile in die Endnote eingeht, aber mach dir keine Gedanken, solange du ordentlich die alte Prüfung angeguckt hast, ist easy.
Leute, macht euch keine Gedanken, die Zwischenprüfung, die IHK-Prüfung sind einfach.
Es geht bei den IHK-Prüfungen, das muss man sich immer überlegen, es geht bei den IHK-Prüfungen nicht um fachliches Know-How.
Das hat zwar oberflächlich den Anschein, hat es aber nicht.
Jeder Noob-Schein.
Jeder Noob-Schein, der sich auf die IHK-Prüfung, wenn er versteht, wie die IHK Fragen stellt und was die IHK für Antworten haben will.
Ihr könnt der krasseste Informatiker-Hackerman sein, wenn ihr noch nie eine IHK-Prüfung gemacht habt, werdet ihr verkacken.
Und ihr könnt der fachfremdeste BWL-Dude sein, wenn ihr euch zwei Monate auf die Prüfung vorbereitet habt, schafft ihr die.
Also so aussagekräftig ist die Abschlussprüfung, beziehungsweise die Zwischenprüfung, die IHK-Prüfung.
Die IHK-Prüfung ist easy.
Wenn ihr noch zusätzlich Ahnung habt und euch ein bisschen...
vorbereitet, dann ist das wirklich gar kein Problem, dass es extrem viel ist und es keinerlei Eingrenzung gibt.
Doch, du kannst das eingrenzen, indem du dir anguckst, was die letzten Jahre drangekommen ist.
Die IHK-Prüfungen sind zu 70% immer das gleiche.
Ich mach mal kurz Package-Updates.
IHK-Prüfungen sind immer der gleiche Shit.
70%.
Neu-Spiegel-DVD-Doku.
Das System IHK.
Würde ich mich sogar zu interviewen lassen.
Wie, es gibt keine Aure?
Package-Updates, was ist denn da los?
Ich verwende Arch, by the way, damit ich täglich fünfmal updaten kann.
Und jetzt kann ich nicht fünfmal updaten.
Das gefällt mir aber nicht.
Oh nein.
Ich hab meine Form wieder kaputt gemacht.
Irgendwas hab ich hier installiert,
dass es komplett
ultra rumspackt,
sobald ich track, track mit der Maus.
Das ist total im Arsch.
Ich weiß nicht, was es ist.
Aber es ist komplett kaputt.
Das ist irgendeine VMware-Geschichte.
Irgendeine VMware-Geschichte.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Das hab ich auf meinem anderen Windows-Account mit VMware-Werkzeichen gar nicht.
Da kann ich track und droppen, wie ich will.
Und das ist nicht kaputt.
Ne, das ist noch VMware 17.
Aber...
Ne, ich hab noch nicht geupdatet.
Ne, das ist es nicht.
Ich mach kein Update auf 17.5.
Ne, hab ich auch nicht vorgehabt.
Aber das ist echt weird.
Das hab ich manchmal.
Wofür die Windows-ME-VM-Diesel übrig geblieben?
Diese Übrigbleibsel.
Massive.
Allerdings danke Leute für die Subs letztens.
Ich hab wieder nicht richtig reingeguckt.
Yes, son.
Mr. Amec hat subscribed vor einer Minute.
Dankeschön.
Play auch am Start.
Huge, Leute.
Das Ding gestern vergessen.
Herr Schocker auch am Start.
Den2Dev auch wieder da.
Darkseid hat gestern subscribed.
Alle sind irgendwie wieder übersehen.
Oder glaub ich zumindest, dass ich übersehen hab.
Satch.
Oh.
Ich hab saumäßig wenig Subs grade.
Also das macht schon was aus.
Ob man regelmäßig streamt oder nicht.
Ich hab in letzter Zeit kaum gestreamt.
Und Instant...
Naja gut.
Ich mein, warum sollte man auch Subs verlängern für jemanden, der nicht streamt?
Das macht ja keinen Sinn.
Würde ich auch nicht machen.
Leute, ich hab heute Mittag wieder was mega ungesundes gegessen.
Und zwar...
Und auch noch viel.
Also nicht einfach nur ungesund, sondern auch noch viel ungesund.
Tintenfischringe.
Also frittierte Tintenfischringe.
Mit Pommes frites.
Und so...
Dipsoße.
Zwei Teller voll.
Und es liegt mir immer noch im Magen.
Ich merk das immer noch, ey.
Keine Subs heißt bald Insi-Modus.
Ja, korrekt.
Also alle subscriben, wenn wir den Insi-Modus abwenden wollen.
Noch eine.
Und was war das ungesunde? Gab's Cola dazu?
Nee, Wasser. Wasser, beste.
Noch eine, alles halt fettig wie Sau.
Und eigentlich nix wirklich Gutes dran.
Noch eine andere Frage.
Kennst du eine Lösung, womit man seine GitLab CI-Config testen kann,
ohne seine Commit-History zu zerschießen?
Hä?
Das versteh ich nicht.
Du meinst Custom-Pipelines?
Die Config für die Custom-Pipelines?
Dass du immer wieder neu pushen musst,
dass du siehst, ob's funktioniert?
Gar nicht.
Einfach Force pushen.
Armenten, Force pushen.
Das ist ein Admin von dem Repo eindeutig,
wenn du CI-Geschichten einrichtest.
Armenten, Force pushen.
Da hast du immer nur einen Commit.
Also, so würde ich das machen.
Mozzarella-Sticks sind auch nice.
Wird mal wieder Zeit für ein Placement-Speedrun?
Dazu müsste ich erstmal ein Youtube-Video machen.
Ja, DarkSide, was hältst du davon?
Armenten, Force pushen.
Das ist doch das Einfachste.
So, jetzt nochmal gucken,
ohne dass ich meine 4M kille.
Gibt's Updates hier.
Leute, wisst ihr,
wisst ihr, was wir uns unbedingt mal zusammen angucken müssen?
Wir müssen uns zusammen mal
NixOS angucken.
Einfach nur, weil's geht.
Ich hab letztens ein Video geguckt,
wo irgendjemand gesagt hat,
es ist zwar unglaublich, aber,
stellt euch vor,
der hat gesagt, er ist von 8-Schlinox umgestiegen
auf
NixOS.
Das glaub ich zwar erst, wenn ich sehe,
ich geh nicht davon aus, dass ich in nächster Zeit
auf irgendwas umsteigen werde.
Aber das, was der in dem Video erzählt,
ich calle auch
Fake. Ja, ich glaub dem
das nämlich auch nicht.
Ich glaub dem, dass
dem Video tut das nämlich auch nicht.
Aber, ich fand das ganz interessant, was der in dem
Video erzählt hat.
Dass du zum Beispiel auch
bei einem Upgrade, was fehlschlägt, zurückrollen
kannst, es dann immer noch geht.
Und dass das im Endeffekt eigentlich,
kein, wie soll man sagen,
so lebendes Betriebssystem ist,
sondern reproduzierbar
sich nach jedem Reboot quasi selbst
wiederherstellen kann, anhand einer
zentralen Config. Die Config sah
bisschen weird aus, so nach dem Motto
sogar meine
X-Config
und I3-Config müsste in der
Main-Config sein und so. Bisschen komisch
ist das Ganze schon, aber
angucken kann man sich's mal.
Ist das wie ein
Docker-Image als OS?
Wie's funktioniert weiß ich nicht.
Da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, wie's
im Hintergrund funktioniert.
Home-Manager hab ich gesehen, aber wenn schon machen wir gleich
NixOS. Home-Manager ist quasi
der NixOS-Package-Manager ohne
NixOS. Also
wie's funktioniert weiß ich nix.
Max, wann gehst du mal wieder
ins Stadion zur Eintracht?
Ich war einmal in
äh, guck sie, dankeschön für den Zap.
Ich war einmal in meinem Leben
bei einem Fußballspiel und das
war tatsächlich bei der Eintracht.
Das ist aber schon ewig her.
Damals hieß das Ding noch
Waldstadion.
Das letzte Mal,
als ich in dem Stadion war und ich hab
vergessen wie's heißt, das hatte ja schon
zwei, drei Namen die letzten Jahre über.
Was ist es mittlerweile?
Commerzbank Arena? Nee, das ist es
auch nicht mehr. Dings Park?
Irgendwas mit Park oder so?
Deutsche Bank Park.
Ja, also da war ich
tatsächlich
letztes...
nein, vorletztes Jahr
bei Chainlaw Park.
Ja, da war ich, da war ich schon.
Also, da war ich vorletztes Jahr
bei Iron Maiden in
Frankfurt und
da wäre ich besser nicht hingegangen
aus zwei Gründen.
Erstens
irgendwie schafft es
keine Location in Frankfurt
gescheiten Sound hinzukriegen.
Aber es war trotzdem nice. Und zweitens
habe ich mit Corona angefangen dabei.
Und das ist eigentlich der Hauptgrund, warum ich da besser
nicht hingegangen wäre.
Warum? Nein, die History ist doch nicht zu geschissen,
wenn du amendest und Force pusht.
Das ist doch gerade der Witz da dran.
Du hast keine Git History
damit. Du amendest immer
deine Changes und Force pusht. Du hast genau
ein Comet. Und das
andere löscht du wieder quasi.
Überschreibst du damit. Du bist, du bist ja
offensichtlich Admin dieses Repos, wenn du
CI-Geschichten einrichtest.
Kannst du es auch so machen.
Amenden, Force pushen. Amenden, Force pushen.
Oder aber
du machst deine History eklig
bis es funktioniert
und dann machst du ein Reset
und machst ein ordentliches Comet.
Nachdem du Admin des Repos
bist, kannst du rumsauen in jedem
Branch wie du willst. Das könnte
ganz... Oh, sadge Leute.
Wisst ihr was gerade gewesen ist?
Meine Tür hat gerade so
komisch geknackst.
Und ich wollte gerade sagen...
Oh, ich glaub meine Katze ist
bestimmt an der Tür und will rein.
Sadge.
Poltergeist bestimmt.
Meinst du sowas wie Gitlaps...
Das ging nicht an mich.
Fear of the Dark.
Ja.
Ich bin ja immer noch der Meinung, es heißt
Fear of the Duck.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du öfters Iron Maiden hörst.
Du kannst es jetzt nicht mehr, nicht mehr
nicht hören.
Es hört sich an, als würde der jedes Mal singen.
Fear of the Dark.
Max, ich muss dich mal was
fragen. Kennst du
gute Kubernetes Monitoring Lösungen?
Da ist die große Preisfrage.
Was willst du
eigentlich genau
monitoren?
Also willst du wirklich den Zustand von
deinem Cluster monitoren?
Willst du den Zustand von deinen
Nodes monitoren? Willst du irgendwelchen
State Content im Cluster monitoren?
Oder willst du die
Anwendungen überwachen, die in
deinen Pods im Cluster laufen?
Willst du zum Beispiel Log-Analyse
machen oder sowas?
Die einfachste Variante,
also aus meiner Sicht, die einfachste
Variante,
easy, simples
Kubernetes Monitoring zu machen ist,
guck mal, was der Cloud-Anbieter
deiner Wahl anbietet, um Alerts
zu setzen für
Logs.
Also bei Google Cloud ist es zum Beispiel so,
dass alle Logs von deinen Pods
automatisch in diesen, boah fragt mich
nicht, wie das heißt, in dieses Log-Bucket
bei Google irgendwie reinkommen
und das kannst du dir dann auch
in der Web-Oberfläche mit dem Log-Explorer
angucken. Der Log-Explorer ist scheiße, der ist
lahm und laggy, aber ist ganz okay,
aber du kannst Alerts
setzen, wenn er bestimmte
Log-Einträge findet
oder ich glaube, man kann auch irgendwie
Negativ-Sachen irgendwie setzen, wenn er
bestimmte Log-Einträge nicht findet oder sowas,
dann kannst du dir einen Alert schicken lassen.
Das ist die simpelste integrierte
und einfachste Variante,
einen groben Überblick zu behalten, was
an den Services gerade funktioniert und
was nicht und wo es Probleme gibt.
Guck dir an,
was dein jeweiliger Cloud-Anbieter
unterstützt.
Bei Azure weiß ich es aus dem Kopf
nicht, ist jetzt schon über
ein Jahr her oder ja, ein Jahr her,
wo ich da zuletzt mit rumgewurscht habe, hauptsächlich
bei mir ist es aktuell Google Cloud. Google hat
das, deswegen würde ich sagen, AWS
und Azure hat das bestimmt auch.
Bei Google
ist es einfach, du gehst dort,
wo der Log-Explorer hin ist, dann gibt es
irgendwo links unten gibt es sowas wie
Notifications und Alerts,
da klickst du drauf, dann kannst du
Notifications anlegen
und dann kannst du so
Queries aus dem Log-Explorer reinpasten,
sobald er was findet, kann er dich über
verschiedene Channels benachrichtigen,
zum Beispiel, das Simpelste ist
wahrscheinlich eine E-Mail schicken, auch im Jahr
2024, ja. Ansonsten
ist das Thema
Kubernetes Monitoring
natürlich ein Fass ohne Boden.
Ich finde aber, man muss es
nicht übertreiben, sondern man muss sich überlegen, was
braucht man?
Meinung zu Health Checks IO,
kann man auch verwenden, wenn man wirklich nur wissen
will, respondet irgendwie
ein Service, wobei Health Checks IO
doch eher was ist, um
nicht wirklich intern für dich
zu monitoren, sondern eher
sowas in Richtung
Status Page, so nach dem
Motto, Service ist weg, ich schreib mal eine
schöne Message,
was denn gerade
Sache ist und sowas.
Meinung zu OpenTelemetry, nice Sache,
ich hab mich noch nicht so
wirklich, also gerade aus
Programmiertechnischer Sicht, wollte ich mich da
in .NET mal mit beschäftigen, noch
nicht so sehr damit beschäftigt.
Außer ein paar Guides angeguckt, im Tutorial
für ASP.NET Core
angeschaut, aber zu wenig, dass
ich da jetzt irgendwie meinen Senf zu
abgeben könnte. Was halt cool ist,
dass du sehr nice Tracen kannst,
durch deine Anwendung durch.
So,
eine Sache muss ich
jetzt aber noch dazu sagen, wie gesagt,
generell Monitoring ist ein Fass ohne Boden.
Aus meiner persönlichen
Erfahrung hat sich
gezeigt, dass viele Läden,
also das war damals beim
Provider so, das war bei der Bank
so, das ist bei der Versicherung so,
dass extremes Overmonitoring
beschreib ich das mal, passiert,
aber im Umkehrschluss nichts
damit gemacht wird. Also es wird in
enorm viel collected an
Daten und es wird enorm
viel gemonitort, aber so
gut wie nichts davon gelangt
jemals in irgendeine
Alert-Regel. Und muss ich halt mal
überlegen, monitoren, nur um des
Monitorens willen, ist unsinnig.
Was sich beim Monitoring
interessiert, ist eigentlich der Alert.
Das ist das, was
meiner persönlichen Meinung
immer ein bisschen
zu kurz kommt. Eigentlich muss man sich
überlegen, wann will ich
Bescheid wissen?
Was ist das, was mich
interessiert, wenn es kaputt geht?
Wann will ich Bescheid wissen?
Ja, man kann nicht immer an
alle Sachen denken und manchmal ist es
sicherlich nicht verkehrt, ein bisschen
mehr einzusammeln, als zu wenig.
Aber was ich
oft gesehen habe ist, es wird auf
jeder Linux-Kiste ein Agent installiert,
es werden erstmal alle Default-Sachen
eingeschaltet,
es wird collected, was das Zeug
hält, dann explodieren dir deine
Storage-Dinger.
Jede Suche ist super
langsam, weil du 30 Millionen Sachen
sammelst am Tag
und du machst damit am Ende nichts.
Und ganz ehrlich, diese ganzen
out-of-the-box-Templates, die es
bei vielen Monitoring-Tools gibt,
halte ich persönlich wenig von.
Gerade wenn man das Thema Kubernetes
Monitoring sich anguckt,
da sind dann ganz merkwürdige
Default-Checks teilweise drin.
RAM-Auslastung über 16%.
Da denke ich mir, ja und? Da kriege ich
wenigstens was für mein Geld.
Habe ich letztens bei Checkmk gesehen,
Node-Auslastung über 16%
Warning.
Und? So what?
Ist doch gut.
Der Node macht wenigstens was für sein Geld.
Das habe ich auch nicht genau
verstanden, warum das da drin ist.
Da gibt es natürlich eine Ausnahme,
wenn es um Anwendungsmetriken
geht, wo
einen der Trend interessiert.
Dann kann man möglichst viele Daten
sammeln, allerdings dann auch nicht
alles.
Wisst ihr zum Beispiel, was ich gesehen habe?
Im letzten Laden, wo ich gearbeitet habe,
die sind irgendwann auf die Idee gekommen,
wir machen Prometheus Monitoring
nicht nur für
Logs,
Schwachsinn, jetzt habe ich Logs
im Chat gelesen und sage Logs.
Wir machen Prometheus Monitoring nicht nur
für Metriken,
wir machen Prometheus Monitoring für alles.
Dann haben die NodeExporter installiert,
SNMP Forwarder,
ähm,
die Anwendungen wurden weiterhin gecrawled.
Das ist explodiert,
die Prometheus Datenbank.
Und am Ende wurde so gut wie nichts alertet
davon.
Der NodeExporter,
guck mal,
es ist ja auch alles am Start,
der Standard
Prometheus NodeExporter,
ich weiß gar nicht, ob das bei denen auf der Webseite steht,
der collectet alles.
Da hast du dann so Dinger wie
SystemD, das ist auch so ein Teil,
wo ich mich aufregen kann, also nicht
SystemD.
Denke mal, die 16%
Node RAM
ist für das Downscalen der Nodes praktisch.
Du meinst, wenn du
dein NodePool verkleinerst, ja,
okay, vielleicht,
aber,
der NodePool war noch auf Minimum,
der war auf 4 Nodes,
kleiner geht es gar nicht.
Also, was auch immer.
Das ist halt das Problem
an Default Checks, das mag durchaus sinnvoll
sein im Fall der Fälle, aber,
halt nicht so pauschal.
Zumindest,
da sammelst du dann so Dinger ein, wie SystemD.
So, da hast du dann
zig Metriken über irgendwelche gestoppten
und gestarteten Services
und irgendwann
kriegst du dann komische
Meldungen, weil
irgendein
SystemD Service
bei Wartungsarbeiten
gestoppt wurde und
keiner mehr weiß, wo man irgendwo
ist.
Das heißt,
du hast dann irgendwie
500 Nachrichten,
weil irgendwelche SystemD,
es ist sinnlos.
Also, um es mal kurz zu machen,
Overmonitoring ist übertrieben.
Und selbst wenn man Metriken collectet,
finde ich es auch nicht sinnvoll,
alle Metriken zu collecten,
die irgendwelche Tools anbieten,
sondern wirklich das,
was einen interessiert.
Das bedeutet es nicht.
Aber wenn man so Trends
analysieren will, also wenn man zum Beispiel
gucken will, wie
eingeloggte User
zu offenen Connections, zu RAM-Auslastungen
sind und sowas in der Richtung.
Ist ja alles sinnvoll,
das in Metriken einzusammeln,
aber man muss es nicht übertreiben.
Also das Wichtigste,
lassen wir es jetzt auch mal gut sein,
das Wichtigste, was man sich beim Monitoring überlegen muss,
ist der Alert.
Vor was habe ich Angst?
Bei was will ich benachrichtigt werden?
Gibt es auch eine Möglichkeit
beim Cloud Provider, die Logs der Applikationen
Ja, das ist das, was ich dir
eigentlich gerade sagen wollte.
In Google Cloud kannst du
in den Log Explorer reingehen
und der Log Explorer, also bei Google Cloud
funktioniert das so.
Google hat
so ein paar Standardsachen in dem Cluster
vorinstalliert. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob man das
also du wirst das Ding ja wahrscheinlich per Terraform
oder irgendwie anders aufbauen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob man das überhaupt konfigurieren kann.
Google hat
dort einen Service
standardmäßig laufen in jedem
Node, der sich nennt
Ist es FluentD?
Ich bin mir gerade
aus dem Kopf gar nicht sicher.
Die haben so einen Managed
Service laufen in diesem, in
jedem Google Kubernetes Cluster,
der deine Applikationslogs einsammelt
und in den Google Log
Storage packt.
Und das ist das, was du, wenn du den Log Explorer
aufmachst, das sieht dann so aus,
hier guck.
Und das schickt Google automatisch weiter
über diesen Managed Service in deinem Cluster.
Kannst du dann auch drinnen suchen
und sonst was. Und das sind deine Anwendungslogs.
Du findest darin auch Clusterlogs,
aber du findest auch den ganz normalen
Log Output von deinen
Containern. Ja, du findest den Cluster,
findest aber auch den Log Output von
deinen Containern drinnen.
Ein bescheides Beispiel finden.
Whatever.
Und darauf
kannst du Alerts setzen. Also wenn du
zum Beispiel eine Anwendung hast,
die ab und zu mal
Exceptions postet und bei einer ganz
speziellen Exception willst du eine E-Mail,
machst du
eine Alert-Regel auf diesen Filter
hier oben drinnen. Ja, du kannst das hier
filtern, hier sieht man es auch schön.
Hier oben kannst du ganz viele verschiedene Sachen
eintragen, nach was du filtern willst.
Du kannst das sogar nach Namespace, in dem dir
der Workload läuft, einschränken.
Ich glaube sogar nach Tags,
nach Annotations im Kubernetes kannst du das einschränken.
Und dann kannst du genau einstellen,
was du willst, dann machst du ein Alert drauf und gut ist.
Das ist die einfachste Variante, wenn man keinen
eigenen Monitoring-Krempel basteln möchte.
Sollte erwähnt, Google bietet
mittlerweile auch Managed Prometheus an
für ihr Kubernetes.
Die gefährlichsten Hacker
der Welt.
Eine Stunde vier.
Heute nicht.
Wir monitoren nicht ordentlich und machen
auch nichts mit den Daten.
Übrigens,
noch eine Sache dazu.
Niemand monitort wirklich ordentlich.
In dem Sinne,
dass du sagen kannst, ja du kannst dich immer komplett
drauf verlassen oder es kommen keine sinnlosen
Meldungen. Also in meinem aktuellen Job ist es
auch so, das Monitoring ist eigentlich
insgesamt relativ gut eingestellt.
Aber es gibt einen Service,
der hat jeden Tag
Monitoring-Meldungen und das sind total
unsinnige Warnings.
Also der hat keine Notifications
und es werden keine Alerts verschickt aufs Handy
oder sowas. Aber der hat jeden Tag,
wenn du in das Monitoring
System reinguckst, machst du das morgens
auf, guckst rein und siehst, aha
fünf Warnings von diesem
Service mal wieder.
Guckst rein, aha, ist der gleiche
Schwachsinn, der jeden Tag drinnen steht, kannst du einfach löschen.
Niemand monitort ordentlich.
Wir haben Private Cloud
Kubernetes.
Was würdest du da empfehlen, um Logs zu
durchsuchen? Aktuell werden die alle an der Liste. Ja, kann man machen.
Ich suche so etwas, wo ich Regeln
als Code definieren kann.
Ähm,
meinst du sowas in der Richtung hier?
Dass du hier so
Search-Queries reinschreibst?
Oder wie?
Dass du hier Search-Queries reinschreiben kannst?
Also, du kannst mal Promtail, also hier
äh, Promtail,
das kannst du dir mal angucken.
Wenn ihr eh schon
Grafana und Prometheus verwendet,
Prometheus braucht
man dafür glaube ich gar nicht.
Aber dann kannst du Queries in
Grafana machen.
Das ist ganz nice.
Falls du das nicht schon kennst.
Getting started.
Haben die gescheite, haben die gescheit...
Ja! Ah, brauchen wir ein gescheites Bild.
Sorry.
Ja. Genau.
LogQL.
Ja.
Dann kannst du solche Abfragen hier machen. Willst du sowas
haben? Promtail und Loki.
Ja. Also Promtail
ist das Ding, was die Logs einsammelt.
Da gibt's, da gibt's aber noch mehr.
Es gibt
noch, äh, wie heißt das andere
Ding? Logstash gibt's glaube ich noch.
Was gibt's denn da alles?
Da gibt's jede Menge.
Fluentbit. Fluentbit ist das, was Google verwendet.
Fluentbit ist das, was Google verwendet,
um, äh, die haben nen Managed Fluentbit
auf jedem Google
Kubernetes Node, auf jedem
GKE Node, der das an den
Google Log Storage schickt.
Craylog. Craylog. War das nicht
Logstash?
Oder bring ich das durcheinander?
Ach, doch. Ach, Logstash ist die Elastik
Geschichte. Deswegen komme ich, denke ich gerade.
Fluentbit und FluentD
ist das gleiche, oder?
Ja, genau. Das finde ich nicht verkehrt.
Man muss ja auch
das Monitoring monitoren. Ja, irgendwann
beißt sich da die Katze in den Schwanz, oder
sagt man die Schlange in den Schwanz? Die Katze in den Schwanz?
Ach, ihr habt, ja genau.
Ihr habt's euch ja
schon angeguckt, gerade im Chat.
Luzi beim Kubernetes Monitoring
in Checkmk, auch den Agent von Checkmk.
Ja, aber das ist scheiße.
Ich mag das Checkmk
bei Kubernetes Monitoring überhaupt nicht.
Ich habe jetzt Managed
Kubernetes eingeschaltet
für unsere GKE Cluster.
Das Problem ist,
dass wir mittlerweile fast mehr
Management Pods am Laufen haben, als
echten Workload in unserem Cluster.
Und dann hast du wiederum das Problem mit
Maximum Pods
pro Node
und IPs, die ausgehen, wenn du nicht
aufpasst.
Ja, Kubernetes ist echt
ein eigenes Ding für sich.
Der Eisenmann...
Der Eisen...
Der Eismann Bepo...
Ich habe der Eisenmann Po gelesen,
gerade. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ja, das ist
eigentlich ein Indikator dafür,
dass die grundsätzlichen Sachen,
wofür man Monitoring braucht, noch gar nicht
erfüllt sind. Ja, sich nämlich darüber
Gedanken zu machen, was für Services
hat man laufen?
Und welche Services davon sind
wie wichtig?
Das ist die Grundvoraussetzung dafür,
damit man Sachen ordentlich monitoren kann.
Damit man auch überhaupt erstmal die Tools
auswählen kann, damit man auch erstmal Regeln
definieren kann, damit man sich Notification
Channels
überlegen kann. Die Grundvoraussetzung
dafür, dass du das überhaupt gescheit machen kannst, ist,
du musst dir erstmal... erster Schritt ist,
was für Services habe ich eigentlich?
Weil wenn du das nicht weißt, kannst du dir
Monitoring komplett schenken.
Was für Services habe ich eigentlich?
So. Oder...
Oder zumindest mal, wenn es
nicht auf Service-Ebene ist, mal zumindest
okay, welche Kisten habe
ich laufen? Du brauchst so eine
Übersicht, was hast du eigentlich?
So. Und wenn du das hast, ist der nächste Schritt zu überlegen,
okay, wie wichtig ist
denn was? Weil es kann ja
durchaus sein, dass du, sagen wir mal, fünf Services
hast, aber der
eine bringt halt ultra viel
Geld und kostet dich auch
mega viel Geld, wenn der ausfällt.
Und die anderen vier sind eher so nice to have
für irgendwelche internen Tools oder so.
Natürlich ist das sinnvoll,
wenn man das für alle Services einrichtet.
Es ist sicherlich auch sinnvoll, wenn man
für alle Services Alert setzt.
Was allerdings nicht sinnvoll ist, ist
für irgendwie...
Service, den zwei Leute benutzen und das auch nur
intern, nachts
um drei irgendjemand aufzuwecken.
Bei einem Service, der dich
ein paar Millionen kostet, wenn er ausfällt,
dann solltest du vielleicht nachts um drei doch
lieber die Leute aufwecken, dass das morgens um sieben wieder läuft.
Mache eigentlich nur
Async Monitoring.
Also Monitoring ist ja
per Definition asynchron.
Was verstehst
du unter Async Monitoring?
Mein synchrones Monitoring
heißt, würde ja heißen,
dein Service hat irgendeinen
Neuro-Link in deinem Hirn
und sobald
irgendwas ist, kriegst du es quasi
im gleichen CPU-Cycle
mit, wie deine Anwendung Probleme hat.
Monitoring ist ja per
Definition irgendwie asynchron, oder?
Soll ich kurz meine Tastatur
rausziehen und wieder reinstecken?
Mein RGB spackt gerade rum.
Zwei Tage später draufschauen.
Ja, dann scheinen sie nicht so wichtig
zu sein.
Finde ich auch nicht verkehrt, sich
alle paar Tage mal so ein bisschen
die Metriken anzugucken, die einen interessieren.
Am Wochenende war bei unserem
RZ-Anbieter Wartung am
Stromfeed A.
Ich ging am Freitag dahin, um
kleine Geräte auf Feed B zu verbinden.
Was passiert? Alles ging offline.
Da hat es herausgekommen, dass beim Raum
die Stromlasten falsch angeschrieben wurden.
Oh, ja, sehr cool. Das ist schlecht.
Aber warum? Wo ist das Problem?
Aktuell waren doch noch beide unter Strom, oder?
Ach nee, als sie die
Wartung gemacht haben, ging dann alles auf.
Nicht als du im RZ warst.
Ja, gut, das ist ja easy.
Da trifft dich ja keine Schuld.
Du hast das ordnungsgemäß ausgeführt.
Du bist kein Elektriker, der
mal kurz die Verkabelung vor dem Vorfeld überprüfen
muss. Geschweige denn, dass du da gar
nicht dran kommst. Und nicht darfst.
Ja, für einfache Sachen ist
das top. Also für wichtige Sachen
willst du Notifications haben.
Und trotzdem jeden Tag reingucken.
Man muss sagen,
so blöd es jetzt klingt,
wenn man eine große
Anzahl von Services hat und darunter liegen
eine große Anzahl von Systemen,
je länger
man die Systeme hat und je besser
man die Systeme kennt,
umso besser erkennst du Probleme
anhand von
irgendwelchen Graphen.
Und von irgendwelchen
Verhaltensauffälligkeiten.
Das ist schwierig zu sagen, immer
ja, genau ab dem Punkt ist der
Schwellwert erreicht und sowas.
Manchmal guckst du dir einfach auch 30 Tage
Verlauf an von
Connections oder
von RAM-Auslastungen zu Usern
zu sonst was und denkst dir, wenn du dir das anguckst,
sag mal, hat das vor einem halben Jahr nicht noch
anders ausgesehen?
Dann gehst du mal ein bisschen zurück und guckst rein
und dann stellst du fest, hä?
Guck mal hier irgendwie,
ab dem und dem Datum
ist das auf einmal ganz merkwürdig.
Da braucht der
Verbindungsaufbau jetzt irgendwie 16 Millisekunden
statt 2 und dann stellst
du fest, ach guck mal da, da gab es ja
einen Release am Wochenende vorher, neue Software-Version
und so haben wir
auch schon die ein oder anderen Bugs in Anwendungen
gefunden. Irgendwie sieht das
merkwürdig aus. Und dieses, dass das
irgendwie merkwürdig aussieht, kriegst
du oftmals nur dadurch raus, dass
du die Systeme kennst mit der Zeit.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz, man muss trotzdem nicht
jeden Schrott monitoren.
Nur das, was einen interessiert.
Also ich muss nicht monitoren,
wie viele
Filehandles irgendein
User offen hat oder sowas.
Einfach nur just for fun auf
jedem System. Ja,
natürlich, das kann mal Probleme machen, wenn
die Filehandles ausgehen, aber
das ist nix, was man
ja, keine Ahnung, das ist nix, was man
im Vorfeld
irgendwie ausschließen will.
Oder,
also ich würde nicht alles
an Filehandles monitoren.
Dann art es total aus, weil du dann irgendwann
sagst, hey, guck mal, dann musst
du auch das, das, das und das und auf einmal hast
du halt wieder terabyteweise irgendwelche Metriken,
die sich keiner anguckt.
Wenn du jetzt irgendwie ein Problem hattest,
ja, weil mal die Filehandles ausgegangen
sind und du sagst, ey, ich will das aber überwachen,
dass das nicht wieder passiert. Ja, vollkommen in Ordnung.
Aber ich finde einfach nur,
sinnlos einsammeln
bringt nix. Es gibt ein paar Sachen,
die man sich immer wieder anguckt,
aber es gibt so viele unsinnigen Metriks.
Mir fällt jetzt leider aus dem
Stehgreif gar nicht so viel gute
Beispiele dazu ein.
Ich müsste jetzt einfach mal irgendwie den Standard
hier, weil wir hatten doch gerade den Node
GitHub Node Exporter
Prometheus.
Gucken wir mal, das explodiert ja
gefühlt auch Gott in die Welt von einem Linux-System.
So, was hast du hier?
ETH Tool.
Brauchst du
wirklich Netzwerk-Statistiken?
Ja, brauchst du, wird jetzt
einer sagen, weil ich will wissen,
Errors, Packet-Loss,
sonst was. Mir persönlich
reicht eigentlich
die Bandbreite.
Dass man mal irgendwelche
Peaks sieht. Disk-Stats, gibt's
auch tausende Sachen, die dich nicht interessieren.
ARP.
Who the fuck cares, irgendwelche ARP-Einträge
auf Linux, ja?
Kannst du den nicht im Einzelfall dazu
einschalten? Ne, das ist tatsächlich nicht so einfach.
Wenn du die Sachen von einem System
einsammelst, per sagen wir hier Prometheus
Node Exporter, dann musst du den erst dann
umkonfigurieren und neu starten.
Bei Prometheus ist das übrigens alles
halb so wild. Prometheus macht enorm
viele Metriken pro Sekunde. Also
das bringst du kaum in die Knie.
Aber ich find's trotzdem immer
Verschwendung und unsinnig, so ultra
viel einzusammeln und davon nur 5% zu benutzen.
Contract!
Juckt auch niemand!
Guckste nie rein!
Wobei, guckste nie rein, stimmt nicht, ich hab mir tatsächlich
schon aktive TCP-Verbindungen angeguckt.
CPU-Frequency, interessiert dich null!
Juck dich null!
Idle Descriptor, guck keine Sau
rein! Pressure!
Was?
SE-Linux-Statistik!
Guck mal, es wird wirklich Gott um die Welt
exportiert, wenn man sich das hier anguckt.
Und da kommt ja noch alles Custom-mäßige
dazu.
Das Wichtigste ist, dass man sich überlegt, was man
braucht, was wie wichtig ist und wofür man
Notifications haben will.
Was hältst du von
Azure Arc?
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt gar keine Ahnung, was Azure Arc ist.
CPU-Last ist interessant.
Es gibt so ein paar Basic-Metriken, die würde ich
tatsächlich von jedem Server sammeln.
CPU-Last, RAM-Auslastung,
Disk-Usage und sowas, das würde ich tatsächlich
machen.
Ob ich da jetzt die Kernel-Entropy-
Informations brauche in meinem
Prometheus, weiß ich nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, was Azure Arc ist.
Stale-NFS-Filehandles?
Klingt ein bisschen so, oder?
Hast du mal einen
Remount probiert?
Hast du mal einen Remount probiert?
Ansonsten ist NFS eklig.
Du kannst auch Force unmounten, aber das mag
NFS oftmals nicht.
Haben wir jetzt eigentlich Updates? Ja, ich habe Updates gemacht.
Und eins noch
zum Schluss, um die Monitoring-Sache
abzuschließen. Es ist immer wieder individuell.
Also das, was ich jetzt hier gesagt habe
und meinen Eindruck widerspiegelt,
kann komplett falsch sein für euch.
Die grundsätzlichen Sachen mit sich
erstmal darüber klar werden, welche Services
man hat, welche wichtig sind, das nicht.
Aber wenn es in eurem Anwendungsfall
Sinn macht, dann monitort mehr.
Es hat ja
keinen Sinn, nur weil irgendwie der random Dude auf Twitch
das jetzt sagt. Wenn ihr denkt,
das ist sinnvoll, dann macht das. Das kommt immer auf
die Umgebung an, was für Leute man
da sitzen hat, was für Services man laufen hat,
wie sich die Infrastruktur zusammensetzt.
Da gibt es keinen Pass für alles.
Ich meine, es gibt Leute,
die haben nur Windows-Server.
Die müssen ja auch irgendwie überwacht werden.
Stellt euch mal vor.
Und dann gibt es ganz verrückte
Leute, die haben da auch noch
PRTG und machen damit dann
Linux-Überwachung und sowas.
Cringe.
Dann ist ja gut.
Der
Wublos ist ja ein bekannter
C++-Fan.
Wie wir alle wissen.
Was haben wir denn eigentlich?
Am Start
was ist das denn?
40 Dinge, die
er realisiert hat.
Oh fuck, Leute.
Wisst ihr, wann ich 40 werde?
Dauert nicht mal lang.
Ich werde
dieses Jahr 40.
Das ist extremely Monarch-S.
Dieses Jahr.
Massive Monarch-S
ist das.
Ich kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen,
dass ich so alt bin.
Wir machen keinen Geburtstags-Stream,
weil ich sage nicht, wann ich Geburtstag habe.
Aber wir machen
in dem Dreh darum
vielleicht Geburtstags-Stream.
Mal gucken.
Ich weiß bloß nicht, was soll ich da überhaupt machen?
Ihr könnt mir alle Primes
haben dann.
Easy.
Ich auch nicht.
Ich meine, Chat.
Wie viele...
Juckts. Am Ohr.
Wie viele
fast 40-jährige Leute
kennt ihr...
Jadiesteel, dankeschön für den Zafferbock.
Wie viele fast 40-jährige
Leute kennt ihr,
die auf Twitch streamen
und laufen irgendwie sowas wie
MonkaS von sich gehen, Mann.
Oder die vor dem Spiegel stehen und sagen
Keckel.
Das ist so...
Einen.
Ja.
Ja, das kommt aber auch
oftmals nur so vor, gell.
Ich meine, wenn man klein ist,
kommen einem Leute mit 20 übelst alt
vor und
die Eltern, die dann irgendwie noch
älter sind, teilweise denkst du sonst was,
wie alt die sind, ja.
Man selbst sieht das immer anders.
Pepega sage ich auch manchmal.
Das, was
ganz schön pock ist, aber auch...
Das checken die meisten nicht, aber
ein paar kapieren es.
Postchamp.
Postchamp sage ich auch, das, ja.
Aber nicht...
Aber eigentlich selten auf der Arbeit.
Postchamp ist eigentlich eines meiner Lieblings-
Lieblings-Emos.
So nach dem Motto, und geht's jetzt?
Postchamp? Postchamp?
Nein, funktioniert nicht.
Schlimm.
Sag mal Leute, verwendet irgendjemand
von euch einen...
Wie nennt man das
gescheit?
Äh, einen Discord-Mods?
Also ich meine
keine Mods auf Discord,
sondern Discord-Modifications.
Sowas wie
zum Beispiel Vencord
oder sowas.
Weil das ist ja the cutest Discord-
Client.
Warum auch immer.
Verwendet jemand sowas? Oder gibt's auch hier
Better Discord? Gibt's da auch noch?
Verwendet er sowas?
Weil das Ding ist folgendes.
Ich hab mal eine Frage an euch.
An die Kenner unter euch.
Ich find das
ja vom Ansatz her sehr nice.
Ich hab mal eine Frage
an euch.
Nein, nein, nein, es geht jetzt nix.
Ich hab mal eine Frage an euch.
An die ganzen Discord-Checker.
Gibt es in Discord eine Möglichkeit,
alle Leute in einem Channel
zu muten?
Wenn es nicht mein Channel ist.
Nein, die Antwort ist, das geht nicht.
Ich weiß, dass das mit offiziellen Mitteln nicht geht.
Aber kennt ihr
eine Discord-Modification
oder ein Plugin, was das kann?
Weil, jetzt mal ein Beispiel.
Ich verstehe übrigens nicht, warum
Discord das nicht kann.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr spielt MMOs
und ihr seid in irgendeinem Raid dabei.
Ja, das bringt ja nix.
Passt mal auf, ich bin ja noch nicht fertig.
Ich bin
noch nicht fertig.
Stellt euch mal vor,
ihr spielt ein MMO und ihr geht in irgendein
was weiß ich,
nehmen wir mal einen 40-Mann-Raid,
wie das früher in World of Warcraft war.
Ihr geht in einen 40-Mann-Raid,
in dem Channel sind alle wild am durcheinander schwätzen
und einer ist halt der Anführer,
der sagt, wo es lang geht.
Ihr wollt alle muten und danach
den Leader wieder entmuten.
Das war früher
zu Urzeiten und so
eigentlich gar kein Problem, noch mit TeamSpeak 2
und haste nicht gesehen, aber
in Discord geht das nicht.
In Discord geht das nur,
wenn du der Channel-Owner
bist und das machst.
Aber vielleicht will ja der Channel-Owner,
dass jeder was sagen kann,
aber ich will nur den einen hören.
Die einzige Möglichkeit,
die ich da bis jetzt gefunden hab, ist,
alle Leute von Hand anzuklicken
und zu muten, was aber nicht
funktioniert, sobald ein neuer reinkommt.
Hintergrund ist folgender,
sag mal,
Chat,
bin ich jetzt
einfach nur blind, oder?
Ist
Nexonus
Name kleiner als
Cursed Kido?
Warum ist dein Name kleiner
als sein Name?
Oder ist das einfach nur die
Groß- und Kleinschreibung?
Ich glaub, das ist einfach nur die Groß- und Kleinschreibung.
Wenn man mal die Os miteinander comparet,
dann sind die gleich groß.
Ich glaub, das sieht einfach nur so aus.
Kannst selbst ein Plugin schreiben,
ja, da brauchst du aber
Discord-Modification dafür.
Ich will das eigentlich
gar nicht selbst machen.
Ich mein, ich kann...
Ich kann doch nicht...
Ich kann doch nicht der Einzige sein,
der
sowas haben will, oder?
Discord mute all.
Also, der Hintergrund ist folgender.
Ich sag euch jetzt mal, worum es genau geht.
Ich hab übrigens schon was heute gefunden.
GitHub Discord
Java API
Da gibt es sogar...
Hier.
Java-Wrapper für Discord.
Da drüber hab ich auch schon geguckt,
ob das möglich ist, aber nein,
das ist nicht möglich.
Gab sogar eine Stack-Overflow-Frage zu.
Dann hätte ich mal sogar was in Java programmiert.
Oder in Java,
wie das die coolen Leute sagen.
Also, Discord-Bot?
Nee!
Discord-Bot müsste ja der Channel,
beziehungsweise der Server-Owner
machen. Ich bin ja einfach nur ein Typ,
der in den Channel reinjoint
und ich will nur für mich alle muten.
Ich will nicht alle muten, die wirklich
in dem Channel sind. Ich will die nur für mich stumm schalten.
Und dass ich nur den Leader höre.
Ja, aber das...
Das scheint's
nicht zu geben.
Also, der Hintergrund ist folgender.
Ich spiele ja öfters MMO,
PvP in einem MMO.
Also, ich spiele immer noch Dark Age of Camelot
seit über 20 Jahren
auf einem Freeshot. So.
Und was wir gerne hätten ist, wir spielen meistens
mit mehr oder weniger den gleichen Leuten.
Bisschen random Leute
immer dabei. Je nachdem, falls mal
einer nicht da ist. Aber wir spielen zum größten Teil immer
mit gleichen, beziehungsweise
ähnlicher Pool an Leuten.
So. Und...
Was echt gut funktioniert ist,
wenn man nicht
mitrennt...
Kreiselgrind, genau.
Wenn man nicht mitrennt im Zerg,
beziehungsweise...
Ich hab das ja schon...
schon mal gestreamt, ja.
Also, da spielen ja ganz viele Leute sinnloses
100 gegen 100
wir rennen uns die Köppe ein.
Das ist nice, das macht auch teilweise Spaß.
Aber, was ich viel nicer finde
ist, oder was wir viel nicer finden
ist, eben mit einer Gruppe rumzulaufen
so, sagen wir mal,
in der Nähe von der
Main Battle Group
und drum herum die Leute abzufarmen.
Ja, vielleicht auch mal ein paar nicer fights
zwischen Gruppen, vielleicht auch mal
die ein oder anderen Nachzügler abfarmen. Einfach...
was machen für uns.
Aber so in der Nähe von der Battle Group,
weil da eben Action ist.
So. Für alles andere
ist das kein Problem, ja.
Wenn man irgendwelche PvP Events macht,
sonst wie was, da geht man in Discord,
8 Mann in den Channel, gut ist.
Überhaupt kein Problem. Wenn man allerdings
um die Battle Group spielen will,
dann...
will ich mit meinen 8 Leuten
im Discord sein,
aber ich möchte den
Battle Group Leader hören,
der in einem ganz anderen Channel ist,
aber niemand, der in dem Channel
drin ist, noch, außer ihm.
Nur ihn.
Oder sie. Ab und zu haben wir tatsächlich
auch weibliche BG Leader.
Ich will nur,
ich will nur den Leader hören.
Und das funzt mit Discord einfach nicht.
Und das nervt mich.
Es ist ja mit Discord schon gar nicht so einfach,
in zwei verschiedenen Channels gleichzeitig zu sein.
Das einzige, was ich bisher rausgefunden habe,
wie man das machen kann, ist,
einmal Discord im Browser und einmal den normalen Client
und joine deine unterschiedlichen Channels.
Das funktioniert. Also,
ich will den Battle Group Leader hören
und im Zweifelsfall vielleicht dem auch was sagen können.
Mal schnell.
Aber ich will niemand
anderes hören. Und ansonsten nur
mit meinen 8 Leuten im anderen Channel sein.
Das geht halt nicht.
Das ist halt richtig
kacke, dass das nicht funktioniert.
Ich weiß gar nicht,
warum das in Discord nicht geht.
Discord ist doch mit entstanden, so als
quasi, ja,
Voice Social Gaming
Plattform.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das umschreiben kann.
Und dass solche Dinger da nicht drin gehen, verstehe ich nicht.
Also, vielleicht kennt ja
irgendjemand von euch da eine Möglichkeit,
Discord Mute All
in dem Channel zu machen.
Und sei es auch nur
mit irgendeinem Plugin für Better Discord oder sowas.
Was ist hier?
Es ist kein Voice Call.
Es ist kein
Voice Call. Es ist ein Discord
Server mit Voice Channel. Und das ist nicht
mein Discord Server. Das funktioniert nicht.
Es sei denn,
das ist kleinseitiges Mute, wie wenn du die Leute
anklickst und stummschaltest.
Doch.
Das eine ist komplett Mute für alle und das andere
ist nur für dich gemutet.
Und Member
klingt schon stark nach, als ich muss
Channel Admin sein oder Server
oder Serverbesitzer. Da bin ich mir
nicht sicher. Das macht berechtigungstechnisch
im Discord sicherlich einen Unterschied.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht geht's.
Ist halt kacke, dass das nicht funktioniert.
Oh, der Chat gekackt gerade ab.
Das, genau! Das versteh ich
gar nicht. Warum geht das in TS?
Gibt es eigentlich irgendjemand, der
TeamSpeak 5 wirklich verwendet?
Ich kenne niemand.
Alle, die TeamSpeak verwenden, verwenden noch
uraltes TeamSpeak. Teilweise noch TeamSpeak 2.
Ich war letztes
Jahr
Dieses Jahr nicht mehr, aber letztes Jahr
ähm, war ich
Wo war das?
Für irgendein Game.
Ich glaub für Warzone.
Ne, das war schon vor zwei Jahren oder so.
Als ich, als ich noch ein bisschen
Warzone gespielt hab, war ich mal
manchmal mit anderen Leuten zusammen
im Voice chatten. Das war TeamSpeak 2
noch. Könnt ihr euch
das vorstellen? Ja, es
gibt TeamSpeak 5. Das sieht jetzt aus wie ein
Discord-Klon.
Sieht auch sehr nach JavaScript aus.
Und
Na okay, vielleicht
nicht Discord-Klon, aber es sieht schon
so aus.
Guckst du mit Chat und allem.
Braucht man nicht einen Account mittlerweile,
wenn du, wenn du TeamSpeak den offiziellen Server
joinen willst? Schon, ja.
Oder, ich weiß es nicht. Also wenn du einen
privaten Server hast, was geht, bis glaube ich 32
Leute, musst du nicht mal Lizenzkosten
für bezahlen, kann man sich immer noch TeamSpeak Server
installieren. TeamSpeak 5
ist glaube ich nur der Client. Wie das Server aussieht,
weiß ich nicht, ob es einen extra TeamSpeak 5 Server
gibt. Ich weiß es nicht.
Habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert. Äh, macht's
auch. Das musst, das findest nicht nur
du, das macht's auch. Je nach
Qualitätssettings und Status von deinem
Discord-Server mal mehr oder weniger.
Ja, TS hört sich besser an. Und TS
hat auch, und das
auch mal mehr oder weniger,
weniger Lackency.
Das ist so.
Das empfindest nicht nur du.
Ich glaube, die sagen am Anfang
auch hier Login, aber das kannst du einfach
überspringen. So, machen wir den Kram mal wieder
zu. So.
Komm, wir gucken uns auch irgendwas
auf YouTube an. Wir haben noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit.
Was haben wir denn noch? Okay. 40
Dinge,
die ich erst mit 40, nach
40 gemerkt hab. Okay.
Pass mal auf. Wir machen jetzt, wir machen jetzt
Fifat. Wir gucken uns einfach die
Kapitel an, ohne das Video anzugucken.
Wir sparen uns jetzt einfach 15 Minuten, okay?
Also.
Was, was, was hat er,
was hat er gelernt?
Was hat er gelernt?
Okay.
Was kommt auf die Gesundheit an? Ja, okay.
Da gebe ich ihm Recht.
Ordentlich pennen ist gesund.
Ja, das stimmt auch. Und so
wie ich es mache, ist falsch, mit einem Handy
im Bett einzupennen, mit
irgendwelchem Schwachsinn streamen,
wo du sinnloses Zeug träumst, weil ein dummer
Stream im Hintergrund läuft.
Ja. Wasser ist der beste
Trink auf der Welt. Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Ja, Wasser.
Ich trinke auch nur Wasser.
Also, naja. Sagen wir mal so.
Die Ruhe ist jetzt übertrieben.
Wenn ich irgendwo beispielsweise am Mittagessen gehe,
dann gibt's da oftmals
nur mini Wasser und das lohnt...
Also, ich trinke zu 99%
und daheim ausschließlich Wasser.
Jetzt auch gerade.
Und das, obwohl mich keiner ans Trinken erinnert hat.
Wasser, beste. Chat.
Sprudelwasser
oder stilles Wasser?
Was sagt ihr?
Still?
Sprudel?
Ich trinke beides.
Ich wechsel da tatsächlich dazwischen.
Ich trinke sowohl stilles
Wasser als auch Sprudelwasser.
Ich finde, Sprudelwasser ist erfrischender
und
löscht den Durst
irgendwie besser.
Aber wenn du
den ganzen Tag
nebenbei was trinkst, bevorzuge ich stilles
Wasser.
Ja. Man sollte öfters
Nein sagen.
Okay. Da hab ich
kein Problem mit. Ich mach eh nur das Nötigste.
Was notwendig ist.
Man soll höflich
sein. Gut, da weiß ich nicht,
was er bei dem Punkt sagt.
Also, es zahlt sich
auf jeden Fall aus, nicht der allergrößte
Spaß zu sein gegenüber anderen
Leuten. Wobei es sicherlich genug Leute
geben wird, die behaupten werden,
genau das Gegenteil zahlt sich aus.
Jaja. Nachdem ich
eh alle anderen Menschen nicht mag,
beschränkt sich meine Interaktion
eh auf ein Minimum.
Es gibt...
Nichts wie zu spät...
Ne, wie kann man das gescheit übersetzen?
Es ist nie zu spät, könnte man das wahrscheinlich
am besten übersetzen.
Ja. Dazu hab ich ja auch letztens
ein Video gemacht. Der Sache stimme ich zu.
Discomfort
is growth. Okay, ja.
Der Sache würde ich auch zustimmen.
Ich hätte auch nicht gedacht,
als ich angefangen habe
zu rennen, dass ich mal über 10
Kilometer am Stück packe, ohne danach
dead get zu sein.
Power is super power.
Ich glaube, der meint nicht damit,
was ich als erstes im Kopf hatte.
Weiß ich nicht, was er dazu sagt.
Man sollte sich nicht selbst
unterschätzen. Ja, okay.
Eh...
Sponsoring?
Wahrscheinlich auch Sponsoring.
Ich bin dumm und das ist
okay. Ja, man muss nicht alles wissen.
Das stimmt. Es ist egal, was
andere Menschen oder andere Leute von einem
denken. Ja, so wirklich
egal ist es einem eigentlich nie.
Aber ich hab das ja auch schon mal in einem Video gesagt.
Es gibt
ganz viele solcher
Coaching-Videos, so
nach dem Motto, ja scheiß drauf, was andere Leute
sagen. Da
fehlt eine ganz wichtige Voraussetzung
für. Damit es einem
egal sein kann, beziehungsweise eigentlich
geht es ja gar nicht ums egal
sein, sondern um sich das nicht so
sehr zu Herzen zu nehmen.
Ja. Ob es jetzt einem wirklich
komplett egal sein soll, was
irgendwelche Leute erzählen
oder überein, weiß ich nicht.
Aber man sollte sich das nicht so zu Herzen nehmen.
Die Grundvoraussetzung dafür ist
allerdings nicht, dass ich mir irgendein Coaching-Video
angucke, wo mir einer sagt, ja scheiß drauf,
was andere von dir denken, Alter.
Ne, das funktioniert nicht.
Damit das funktioniert,
dass man sich die Sachen, die
andere überein sagen, nicht mehr so zu Herzen
nimmt, ist, dass man mit sich
selbst irgendwie so...
Wie nennt man das?
Im Reinen ist das
das falsche Wort. Ja, dass man mit sich selbst
halbwegs zufrieden ist, ja.
Dass man auch mal
in sich gegangen ist,
dass man auch mal weiß,
was man nicht kann, was man gut
kann, dass einen
andere Leute eben nicht so
einfach kränken können mit irgendwas,
weil man eben die Wahrheit nicht hören kann
oder so, ja.
Oder sich überall darüber aufregt.
Also man muss halbwegs mit sich irgendwie
mal zufrieden sein, erst
dann wird es einem wirklich egal sein.
Was andere Leute überein
denken, beziehungsweise dann nimmt man sich
es auch nicht mal so zu Herzen.
Weil wenn man permanente Selbstzweifel hat,
dann wird das nix.
Okay. Nicht versuchen, Leute zu
beeindrucken,
sondern Value adden. Das klingt nach
diagonal skalieren.
Blaming is stupid. Kommt drauf an,
wenn man Recht hat, nicht.
No one is coming to save me.
Okay. Oh.
Ja, das fällt bei mir eh flach.
Stop looking at the rearview mirror.
Ja, das glaube ich, das machen
auch viele Leute nicht.
Also, ich gehe davon aus, dass er nicht wirklich
ins Auto gucken, in den Rückspiegel
gucken meint. Ich gehe davon aus, dass er meint,
es hat keinen Sinn, immer wieder zu sagen,
ey, hätte
ich das und das mal anders gemacht, ja.
Habe ich auch letztens ein Video dazu gemacht.
An Weihnachten.
Boah, das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Äh, kein Bock jetzt.
Ich glaube, viele Leute realisieren
zu ähnlichen Zeiten ähnliche
Sachen. Für manches, für manches
muss man einfach ein bisschen älter sein.
Und umgedreht, umgedreht
ist es auch so, manche Sachen, die man
mega nice fand, während man jung war,
findet man jetzt nicht so gut und
umgedreht findet man Sachen
gut, die man früher scheiße fand.
Ich glaube, so geht es jedem.
Ja, du hast Recht, aber du hast noch nie
irgendwelche Competitive Multiplayer
Spiele gespielt, oder?
Das erste, was passiert
ist,
meine Teammates sind scheiße, Mann.
Why you play like shit?
Das ist normal.
Die sind alle am Rumpflame immer.
Und in MOBAs ganz besonders
schlimm. Deswegen spiele ich auch keine
MOBAs.
Ja,
Business Context, gebe ich dir Recht.
Aber selbst da hast du Leute, die sind einfach nur
nervig und manchmal
musst du dann auch mal was sagen.
Manchmal musst du es auch echt ansprechen,
wenn die Leute immer Scheiße bauen.
Der Neo-Wim-Stream, ne,
den muss ich noch machen.
Quality is Destiny.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es dieses Video gibt auf YouTube.
Es gibt so einen...
Moment.
You play
like shit.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das Video gibt.
Ne.
Ach shit, ich finde es jetzt nicht.
Es gibt so einen, wie gesagt,
ich spiele ein 20 Jahre altes MMO
und
einer der Battlegroup-Leader
ist ein Deutscher
und da gibt es so einen Voice-Clip von dem,
wo er ganz laut rumschreit
You play like shit.
Aber übelst am ausrasten ist.
Gibt es leider nicht auf YouTube.
Also, wo wir gerade dabei sind, ne,
dass man andere Leute nicht flamen soll.
In Multiplayer-Spielen wird
immer rum geflamed. Das geht, glaube ich, nicht anders.
Wobei, also,
das würde schon anders gehen.
Aber die Natur der Sache
in Team-Multiplayer-Spielen
ist einfach, dass
die Leute gerne
Teammates flamen.
Es ist ja auch einfach, Teammates zu flamen
und nicht so in Multiplayer-Spielen allgemein,
weil dann muss man sich nicht selbst
darüber Gedanken machen, dass man es vielleicht verkackt hat.
Hey, es gibt
in Spielen immer wieder die Situation,
dass es kacke ist,
was deine Teammates machen. Aber manchmal,
und das trifft bei Multiplayer-Spielen öfters zu,
als einem lieb ist, manchmal ist es so,
dass es wichtig ist,
zusammen Scheiße zu machen in einem Multiplayer-Spiel,
anstatt alleine das Richtige.
Wisst ihr, was ich meine?
Stellt euch mal vor,
ihr spielt jetzt irgendeinen,
stellt euch vor, ihr spielt irgendeinen Shooter
oder irgendeinen Strategiespieler, ist egal.
Und irgendeiner sagt, so Leute,
wir gehen jetzt da hin.
Es ist die bescheuertste Idee ever
aus eurer Sicht, dort jetzt hinzugehen.
Und
was passiert ist,
ihr geht an den Spot, der
vielleicht Game-Theorie-technisch
der bessere wäre, aber alleine,
und die anderen vier gehen auf den schlechten Spot
und verrecken dort
vier gegen fünf.
Dann wäre es wahrscheinlich besser gewesen, ihr hättet gesagt,
scheiß drauf, es ist zwar dumm,
aber ich geh mit.
Also gerade in Multiplayer-Spielen ist es manchmal sinnvoll,
zusammen das Falsche
zu machen.
Und wahrscheinlich kann man das auch auf
noch ganz viele andere Situationen übertragen.
Was ist das denn?
Wie Android und IOS
das Windows Phone zerstörten.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob die das zerstören mussten.
Ich habe irgendwie den Eindruck gehabt, Microsoft hat
da selbst dafür gesorgt, dass
Chiropraktiker effektiv...
What the fuck?
Da krieg ich immer Videos empfoh...
Wow.
Da krieg ich immer Videos von empfohlen,
in Shorts, auf meinem Handy,
wenn ich abends
äh, wenn ich abends
das Handy aufmache,
da krieg ich immer Shorts empfohlen auf YouTube
von irgendwelchen Leuten, die anderen
Leuten so, so
Gelenke knacken und so, so ganz
merkwürdiger Content.
Und habt ihr auch manchmal das Problem,
dass die YouTube-App auf
eurem Handy automatisch beim Öffnen
einen Short startet, obwohl ihr gar
keinen Short gucken wollt. Ihr macht die
Handy-App auf und auf einmal startet ein Short.
Ich denk mir dann immer,
ich bin mit dem Finger irgendwo draufgekommen,
aber ich glaube, das ist
Bild-In-Funktionalität von YouTube.
YouTube denkt jetzt,
du musst dir einen Short angucken.
Ich hab kein Android.
Warum Software-Entwickler immer schuld sind,
weil Manager-Leute nicht checken, was sie machen.
Und es einfach ist, Entwickler zu blamen.
Oder generell
Technikleute zu blamen.
Anstatt beschissene Planung.
Was ist das?
List of the disastrous
US measure system.
Oh yeah.
Ja.
Gut.
Ist da BTU drinne?
Wo ist BTU drinne?
BTU ist die sinnloseste Einheit ever, Mann.
Chatge, ihr wisst natürlich alle,
was BTU ist.
Oder noch besser,
BTU pro Stunde.
Auch eine ganz tolle Einheit.
7.15 kommt BTU.
BTU, Mann.
Das ist die beschissenste Einheit ever.
Also wer sich fragt,
was BTU ist,
das ist,
ein BTU ist definiert als die Wärmeenergie,
die benötigt wird,
ein britisches Hund Wasser
um ein Grad Fahrenheit zu erwärmen.
Da weißt du Bescheid, oder?
Und das Schlimme ist,
die Einheit wird heutzutage
tatsächlich benutzt.
Beispielsweise bei USVs
wird die benutzt.
Also,
wenn ihr eine USV kauft,
ist es nicht
unwahrscheinlich,
dass dort was von BTU draufsteht.
SebiDev, danke für den Sub.
Klimaanlagen, ja?
Klimaanlagen auch.
Was sagt der denn zu BTU?
Hey, britische Thermal Units.
Ein BTU ist die Anzahl der Energie,
die benötigt wird,
um einen Pound Wasser
um einen Grad Fahrenheit zu erwärmen.
Ja, genau.
Es ist in der Industrie
üblich akzeptiert,
die Anzahl der Btus pro Stunde
um nur Btus zu sein,
und es wird als pro Stunde bezeichnet.
D-Tier.
Nächster Punkt Thau,
auch bekannt als 1,001 Inch.
Was sagt denn diese Tierliste?
Horsepower.
Ja, Horsepower geht noch klar.
Das hat ja nichts mit unserer Tonne zu tun,
nehme ich mal an.
Inch? Acker?
Hektar? Nee.
Acker.
Inches of Water.
Inches of Mercury.
Was soll das?
Ounce.
Ja, Ounces macht mich auch immer durcheinander.
Ounces macht mich auch immer durcheinander.
Gerade wenn du bei Amazon guckst
und guckst Logitech Maus.
Fünf Ounces.
Fluid Ounce.
Yard.
Yard ist auch so ein Kokona Ding, Mann.
Nee, ich schau nicht das Video.
Um zu so einer Liste zu kommen.
Galen. Galen ist auch so ein Kakab.
Ja.
Das ist schon ziemlicher Schrott.
Aber die Ami stehen da drauf.
Kokona Time.
Er erklärt alles.
Eine Sache, die mich immer irritiert ist,
wenn Leute
Kilowattstunde
als
schreiben.
Weil die es wahrscheinlich von
kennen.
Es sieht ähnlich aus, ist aber komplett falsch.
Weil es ist nicht
durch die Strecke.
Oder durch die Zeit.
Sondern es ist Mahlzeit.
Es ist Kilowatt Mahlzeit.
Ist auch ein bisschen doof.
Erkennt man beim Aussprechen nicht.
Ist aber
komplett falsch.
Irgendwie sagen mir YouTube Videos gar nicht zu.
Wir kriegen immer noch super krasse Weep-Musik empfohlen.
Weil ich einmal was abgespielt habe.
Weep-Musik am Start.
Offizieller Mod-Support
von Baldur's Gate 3.
Ja, die machen schon einiges richtig mit dem Game.
Das ist genau das, was das Game
langfristig noch am Leben hält.
Das hat einen riesen Hype gehabt.
Und auch immer noch sau viel Content dazu produziert wird.
Wird aber früher oder später halt einschlafen.
Aber mit Mod-Support, also
mit offiziellem Mod-Support,
könnte ich mir echt vorstellen, dass da einiges...
Wobei, hat das nicht
schon seit Anfang an offiziellen
Mod-Support gehabt?
Oder war das so ein halb offizieller
ding, so nach dem Motto
Ja, wir
versuchen
das möglichst stable zu halten,
können aber nix versprechen oder so.
The first quadruple A
Game. Genau. Das ist auch wieder
so ein Market. Also sobald der Typ was
erzählt hat von AAAA
Game, weißt du, wusstest du doch sofort,
dass Bullshit erzählt wird.
Achtung, Sicherheitswarnung.
Tasmota. Warum?
Aber es ist halt hier ein dummer
wirklich ein dummer
kleiner Konfigurationsfehler
unterlaufen.
Ja, da ist
nix. Zumal die
erstmal ins WLAN rein
kommen müssen.
Warum kriege ich eigentlich so viel Shit empfohlen?
Kein Passwort
gesetzt. Ja, aber selbst wenn.
Macht ja auch nix.
Also, vielleicht nicht das sinnvollste.
Aber macht ja auch nix. Das Ding
hängt ja im WLAN. Da muss erstmal einer in einem WLAN sein,
dass er drauf zugreifen kann.
Also insofern,
versteh ich nicht.
Was sind das für Shorts?
YouTube meint, das will ich
mir angucken. Man muss aber dazu
sagen, YouTube hat meine
Watch History verloren.
Vor ner Woche. Und wir haben
kaum Videos bisher aufgehabt. Deswegen
weiß YouTube nicht so
genau, was wir uns eigentlich angucken
wollen. Battlefront Classic
ist inzwischen über 20 Jahre alt.
Ah ja.
Viele gute Spiele sind mittlerweile
über 20 Jahre alt.
Kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Und wisst ihr, das ist eines der Sachen, woran
ich wirklich merke, dass ich alt bin.
Auch wenn es mir wirklich nicht so lange her
vorkommt. Ich kann mich dran
erinnern, wo ich das erste Mal Half-Life gespielt
hab. So 1998,
1999 rum.
Und das ist 25
Jahre her. Kann man sich gar nicht
vorstellen. Mir kommt das wirklich
nicht so lange vor.
Ein Vierteljahrhundert ist das her.
Wo ich Half-Life
gespielt hab, das erste Mal.
Und CS 1.5 gab's damals noch nicht.
Ich kann mich
noch dran erinnern, als CS 0er Version
hatte. CS 0.5.2
und sowas. Als es noch nicht mal
ein automatisch
wie nennt sich das so, dynamisches
Fadenkreuz gegeben hat.
Was übrigens viele Leute, als es neu war, kacke fanden.
Könnt ihr euch vorstellen, dass Leute
Dust 2 scheiße fanden zu Release?
Kein Witz.
Als Dust 2 rausgekommen ist,
fanden es die Leute kacke.
Die haben gesagt, so eine uninspirierte Kack-Map
Damals haben ja auch viele Leute
gerne Geisel-Rettung gespielt.
Das hieß ja nicht umsonst CS in den Maps.
Ich hab gerne Assault
gespielt. Das ist diese Map mit dem Lüftungsschacht.
Keine Ahnung, ob's die noch gibt.
Die Map mit dem Lüftungsschacht war nice.
Da konnte man immer den Lüftungsschacht campen.
Ja.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, als ich das zum ersten Mal
gespielt hab. Ich war so
unglaublich schlecht, Mann.
Ich hab mich damals angestellt,
ich war echt wie der letzte Mensch,
was so Spiele angeht.
Ich weiß noch,
ich glaube,
dass
Super Mario World auf Super Nintendo
das kannst du ja heutzutage
easy an einem Tag
locker durchspielen, auch wenn du kein Speedrunner bist.
innerhalb von ein paar Stunden,
auch wenn du kein Speedrunner bist.
Und auch ohne, dass du
jetzt nur Star World, Star Road
Shortcuts nimmst.
Das kannst du easy in ein paar Stunden durchspielen.
Du kannst die komplett ausruten.
Es ist easy, ja.
Und das ist auch gar nicht schwer, wenn man
heutzutage 20, 30 Jahre
Spielerfahrung hat. Aber Leute, ich sag euch,
das war echt
schwer für mich damals.
Das war echt schwer.
Ich hab bestimmt
zwei Monate gebraucht
oder so.
Bis ich Super Mario World
auf Super Nintendo durchgespielt habe.
Und das war echt schwer.
Danach ging das immer
besser, easy und alles.
Aber das war ja auch eines der ersten
Plattformer, die ich gespielt habe.
Ich glaube, davor habe ich nur
das allererste
Mario-Spiel, was ich gespielt habe,
war glaube ich damals auf dem Game Boy
das allererste Super Mario Land,
was ein richtig, naja,
vielleicht jetzt nicht Kack-Game ist,
aber
finde ich heute auch noch
kein sonderlich gutes Spiel.
Ich weiß nur noch nicht so genau, was sie da treiben
bei Nintendo. Das zweite war deutlich besser.
Also meine erste Konsole,
die ich hatte, war tatsächlich ein Game Boy.
Ein Game Boy mit Tetris und Super Mario Land.
Ich weiß nicht genau wann,
aber müsste wahrscheinlich schon so
1989,
90 oder so gewesen sein.
Wann kam denn der
Game Boy raus?
Na ne, dann ein bisschen später.
Dann wahrscheinlich
eher 1990 oder so.
Dann hatten wir
relativ schnell ein Super Nintendo.
Erste, erste
Super Mario World F-Zero war glaube ich dabei.
Und ein paar andere Sachen,
die ich mir dann später gekauft habe.
Die waren damals mega teuer, die Spiele.
Ja.
Und als ich, als ich,
als ich
A Link to the Past gespielt habe auf dem
Super Nintendo
zum ersten Mal, ich war so schlecht.
Ich war so schlecht.
Ihr müsst euch vorstellen, ich habe
lange nicht mal das Tutorial geschafft.
Also hier,
ähm, Escape, wie sich das
heute bei den, bei den Speedrunner
nennt. Also das Schloss
und, und Escape.
Ich habe es nicht geschafft.
Ich habe es nicht gecheckt.
Da gibt es doch diese Stelle,
wo man im,
im Thronsaal
diesen Schrank wegschieben muss.
Und ich habe es einfach nicht gecheckt.
Und als ich es endlich gecheckt habe, habe ich mir gedacht,
wow, jawoll, geschafft.
Dieser ganze Escape durch den, durch den,
äh, durch die
Kanalisation da, da bin ich so
oft verreckt. Ich hatte fast keinen Bock mehr,
das Spiel weiter zu spielen, weil ich so schlecht
war damals.
Wind Waker ist auch schon 20, kann man sich kaum vorstellen,
ja. Ich war damals
immer sad, weil ich kein Gamecube hatte
und Wind Waker nicht spielen konnte.
Ja, mal gucken, wann sie da die Server abschalten.
Sonic habe ich auch nie geschafft.
Das lag aber wahrscheinlich mit
daran, weil ich selbst kein,
äh, keine Sega-Konsole hatte, sondern
das immer beim Kollegen aus der Schule gespielt habe.
Ich hatte einen Super Nintendo, der hatte,
der hatte das Teil von,
war das der Mega Drive damals von Sega?
Ich glaube schon.
Und der hatte so, der hatte
die Sega-Kiste.
Was eigentlich ganz nice war, da konnte man nämlich
beides spielen.
Und
ich war auch zu unfähig für Sonic.
Ich habe es durchgespielt, ich habe aber auch
wieder ewig gebraucht. Also wie gesagt,
ich habe Monate für Super Mario World gebraucht
auf Super Nintendo und A Link to the Past
habe ich auch Monate
gespielt, bis ich da durch bin, man.
Ich hatte, ich meine, ich war da klein, ne?
Ich hatte übelst Schiss.
Ja, vorstell mal, was ist das?
A Link to the Past
Release Day 1993
oder sowas? 1991,
Alter, wie alt war ich denn da?
91, äh, 84
bin ich gef... 7.
Okay, aber ich hatte es ein Jahr später, 8.
Ich hatte, ich hatte
in... Ich hatte Schiss,
vor der Dark World in A Link to the Past.
Und
dementsprechend konnte ich immer nur spielen,
wenn meine Mutter dabei war.
Ich hatte übelst
Schiss vor den Dark World Dungeons,
weil die so gruselig waren mit 8.
Und ich bin
dann eigentlich hauptsächlich im Dorf rumgelaufen
die ganze Zeit und habe dort
alles, was es gab,
rausgefunden, so.
Ja, das waren echt Zeiten, man.
Aber ich habe es
durchgespielt.
Nach Wochen,
wenn nicht Monaten, die ich dafür
gebraucht habe. Also mein
Super Nintendo habe ich noch, ein paar Super Nintendo
Spiele habe ich auch noch.
Was ich auch noch habe, ist
die N64 Cartridges.
Aber leider habe ich mein N64 nicht
mehr. Was hältst du von
Palo Alto? Ich habe mit Palo Alto
persönlich nie was gemacht. Dort, wo ich
letztes Unternehmen, wo ich gearbeitet habe,
die hatten eine Firewall von Palo Alto.
Ich glaube, das ging allen so,
wie sie klein waren, dass die
bei eigentlich nicht gruseligen Spielen
halt übelst
Schiss hatten. Aber das liegt
an zwei Sachen. Erstens,
weil man jung war und auch enorm viel
Vorstellungskraft hatte, was das angeht.
Und eine Sache, die
bei mir bis heute immer noch andauert.
Ich kann mich
vorstellungskraftmäßig in
Pixel Games viel besser reinversetzen
als in reale Games.
So bescheuert
sich das anhört, weil
bei dem einen musst du dir ja gar
nicht viel vorstellen,
aber ich glaube, gerade das ist es, dass
du dir eben nicht selbst drumherum
vorstellen musst. Und bei
Pixel Games halt
schon. Weiß nicht, habe ich nichts
zu reale
Games wie Brettspiele.
Mit meinem Opa habe ich immer Mensch ärgere dich nicht
gespielt. Aber ansonsten mag
ich keine Brettspiele.
Gibt es
ähm
Brettspiel-Enjoyer?
So, ich muss grad mal auf dem Handy was
nachgucken.
Steiner, dankeschön für den Sub.
Gerade eine Ausbildungsstelle gefunden. Ist das
realistisch?
Moment. Ist es realistisch, folgendes
in einer Physie-Ausbildung alles zu lernen?
Kommt mir viel vor.
Weiß nicht, lass mal reingucken.
Kann ich das aufmachen? Ja, okay, kann
man aufmachen. Muss immer ein bisschen vorsichtig
sein, weil ich hier im Stream einfach anklicke.
Wer weiß nicht, dass da Booba gezeigt wird.
Und ich krieg Probleme.
Also,
Schwerpunkt
ähm
In welchem Kontext ist das jetzt?
Stellenanzeige für
äh, also der Kontext
würde mich jetzt schon interessieren. So, Physie?
Physie-Ausbildung und da steht dann irgendwie
ein Abteilungs, äh, ein Abschnitt
drinne. Das lernen sie bei uns, oder
wie? Oder wie darf ich mir das vorstellen?
Okay, Schwerpunkt Netzwerktechnik
in unserem Online-Server-Team.
Systemadministration
Linux, Windows, Mac.
Ja, allein schon das ist blödsinnig. Okay,
in der Ausbildung ist es nicht ganz so
blödsinnig, weil viele Unternehmen machen
das ja so, dass du in der Ausbildung
ein paar Stationen durchgehst
und da kann es durchaus sein, dass
du mal in einem Linux, in einem Windows
und in einem Mac-Team landest, wobei
ich wenige Unternehmen kenne, die das
alles gleichermaßen gewichtet
haben. Ja,
aber du wirst ja schon relativ schnell feststellen,
dass du auf Windows Kacke findest und
lieber Linux machst.
Gehe ich zumindest mal von aus.
Ähm, Verwendung von
Virtualisierungstechnologien, vor allem
wie ist es für Docker, AWS,
EC,
Elastic.
Warum heißt bei Amazon
alles Elastic, Mann?
Das ist das Schlimmste
bei AWS, ohne Scheiß. Ich habe
mit AWS noch nicht viel gemacht,
aber bei AWS ist alles so super kryptisch
bescheuert benannt.
Okay. Verwendung
von Virtualisierungstechnologien, vor allem
Docker, AWS,
Automatisierung von Installationsprozessen,
Puppet, Vagrant!
Puppet und Vagrant!
Okay, Puppet ist wirklich
outdated, overrated, jebaited.
Es gibt noch ein paar, die das haben, aber
du findest kaum noch Leute dafür.
Ansible ist
the way to go und Vagrant
Vagrant ist übrigens
von den gleichen Leuten,
die auch Terraform und
Consul und
Vault und
was haben die noch so alles
gebaut haben. Vagrant
war das allererste Projekt von dem Typ,
von den Typen, aber
fällt eigentlich keiner mal ein, der noch wirklich
Vagrant benutzt.
Administration von Storage-Systemen,
VMware-SAR, NetApp,
Log-Management, Elastic-Stack, Kibana,
Logstash. Warum
eigentlich alle drei?
Warum? Okay.
Monitoring der Systeme,
Checkmk, OMOD.
Was ist OMOD?
O, O, ne
OMD.
Monitoring.
Open Monitoring
Distribution.
Ach, das ist Checkmk
als fertiger Installer, oder was?
Metricbeats
Plugins. Administration
und Configuration von verteilten Datenbanksystemen
per Kona,
Solr. Ist
Solr nicht
ein Search-Engine-Kram?
Administration und Konfiguration
von Key-Value-Stores, Redis, Memcache,
RapidMQ,
Apache, PHP,
FPM. Okay.
Administration der internen Netze.
IOS.
Übrigens nicht mit Apple zu verwechseln.
Das Zeug hieß schon IOS, bevor
IOS, IOS war.
Administration der produktiven und
Standard Firewall FortiGuard,
FortiGuard PF-Sense,
VPN-Lösungs... PF-Sense,
Loadbalancer,
HA-Proxy, F5,
Apache,
Einrichtung und Überwachung von Backup-Lösungen,
Backup-PC,
da haben sie aber auch alles drin,
LVM, Shell-Skripte,
Installation, Configuration,
Warteproduktiv-Lösungs-Server, Installation,
Update der eingesetzten Software, übrigens Open-Source,
Konzeption von Server-Architektur,
Störungs- und Problem-Management, Sicherung
und Widerherstellung. Also Chat,
ja, das kann man während der
Ausbildung schon alles lernen. Das wirst du
es nicht alles im Detail, in der Tiefe lernen,
dass du sagst, ich bin ein Experte, da drin,
da drin, da drin, da drin, da drin,
da drin, da drin, da drin, aber mach die Themen
alle Streifen in der Ausbildung, klar,
warum nicht? Ja, das, das,
da gebe ich, gebe ich euch recht, Chat,
das liest sich etwas
wildwüchsig, das stimmt,
aber das kommt wahrscheinlich
daher, weil es den Laden schon eine
Weile gibt, die haben da, die haben mit
Puppet angefangen, sind gerade am Umbauen
auf Ansible, haben,
ja, das, das, das,
ich meine, ich bin ja froh, dass hier keine
Checkpoint-Firewall mehr drinsteht. Kennt
den Krempel noch jemand von früher?
Checkpoint-Firewall 1?
Ja,
ich erinnere,
dunkel, Alter,
ja, genau so sah
das aus, Mann, so
sah das aus. Ich weiß
gar nicht, wie das jetzt aussieht, gibt es das überhaupt noch?
Aber man sieht, das ist aber
richtig aktuell, guck mal,
es wird unterstützt, Solaris
8, 9, 10, Windows 2000,
2003 Server,
Red Hat 3
und Nokia
IP so, keine Ahnung.
Okay,
den Kram gibt es ernsthaft immer noch.
Wisst ihr, wenn ich auf der
Webseite kein
Screenshot vom
Management Interface sehe, weiß
ich, es ist einfach nur Business Enterprise
Geschwubbel und Scheiße.
Hey, iCheck.
Na, alles richtig im Detail kann man ja davon
gar nicht können.
Historisch gewachsen, genau.
Okay, Leute, ich muss jetzt ins Bett gehen.
Schon spät,
Boomer müde, Boomer schlafen.
Du findest sicherlich was in der
Ausbildung, was dich interessiert
und dann
kannst du den anderen Kram skippen.
Alles klar. So, Leute, ich muss
ins Bett. Wir hören uns, bis dann.
Macht's gut.
See you.